[موسيقى]
تقريبا بعمل وانا عندي سبع سنين
يعني تقريبا مثلا يوميا او اسبوعين كل
فتره
بس
اللي هو كده رقم تمانيه وبعد كده بدات بقى
اغير
المربعات اللي زي كده
[موسيقى]
يعني كل كارت بتحكم فيه هو لوحده بس فكان
صعب في الاول موضوع ان انا ارسمه يطلع بس
يعني مؤخرا بقت الدنيا بقت الذ بكثير بقت
الطف كثير يعني مؤخرا بقت لا بعرف ان انا
اطلع ان انا برسمه وبقيت بعرف اطلعه
بتفاصيل اكتر
[موسيقى]
يعني هو في كذا كذا حاجه يعني كان في اكبر
ما كطول كان 3 متر و8 سم
ده رابع على ارتفاع في العالم فهو بيبقى
على حسب كل مكاتب يعني كل بالنسبه لي
بيبقى هو مميز في حاجه معينه لكن اكبر
حاجتين هما يعتبر 57
واللي هو البرج اللي هو كان اللي هو كان
تلاته يعني مثلا ممكن يبدا من من ست ساعات
لغايه ممكن
[موسيقى]
300 حاجه في الرنج ده
300 ساعه ممكن حاجات تبقى اكثر من كده
يعني بس لسه انا ما دخلتش في الجزء ده بس
انا اخر حاجه
يعني انا لو لو مش بجدد او مش مغاير كان
ممكن يبقى عندي مثلا 1000 قلب او حاجه
يعني فانا بجد على طول باستمرار عندي
تقريبا دلوقتي حوالي
300 علبه او 300 وشويه بس اكيد هم 600
بحاول بقى كل فتره بجيب كروت اكثر ومؤخرا
كمان بقيت بجيب اونو
يعني بقيت بنوع في اشكال الكوتشينه عامه
لان بيبقى مثلا في حاجات محتاجه الوان
فبحتاج ان انا اجيب الوان زي مثلا محمد
صلاح لما جيت عملته عنده شعر كتير جدا مش
هينفع يتعمل فاقولوا مثلا هيبقى لونها
اسود فهتبقى قريبه شويه مثلا لما عملتها
كانت الشبسه نفسها لونها اسود فمش هينفع
برده
بتبقى في حاجات خليك انت عايزه تجيبي كروت
بنوع معين عشان تعرفي توظفيها يعني
[موسيقى]
انا يعني كنت حابب الماكينه كنت مبسوط ان
انا عملته يعني كان صعب جدا ان انا اعمله
يعني ما كنتش متوقع ان انا اعمله بصراحه
كنت متوقع ان هو يتهدى في النص بتاعه
مبسوط ان انا عملت يمكن اربع او خمس ايام
زياده عن اللي هو قعد لكن ما افتكرش ايه
اصلا بقى مهتم ان انا اهده عشان ابني جديد
وبتاع وعايز اعمل اكتر مهتم اوي انا كده
[موسيقى]
اصلا بتبقى على حسب اصلا انا عايز اعمل
ايه تمام يعني مثلا لو افترضنا ان انا
عايز اعمل استاد فاهماني مثلا لو الرقم
اللي هستخدمه هيبقى مثلا رقم عشره ليه
تحديدا رقم عشره مع لما يكون كتير جدا ومع
زاويه بعيده بيبان ان هو نقاط كتير فبيبان
ان هو جمهور
يعني بتبقى على حسب انا بهده ازاي يعني
مثلا في مثلا مكان معين اللي هو مثلا
الكروت من نص مثلا ده بيبقى هو ده اللي
اسمه عصب الارتكاز بتاع الماكيت كله فده
يوقعه على طول في مثلا ممكن بقى من
الاجناب نقعد مثلا نهد مثلا دور من هنا
ودور من هنا ومش عارف ايه بياخد وقت شويه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات